dozens of ecuadorians gathered outside
this prison on saturday waiting for any
news of their family members
there was an overnight riot at the
littoral penitentiary in the southern
city of guayaquil that began on friday
evening
information is difficult to come by
they desperately looked through an
unofficial list of victims names that
was posted outside the building
i'm hoping that my son is one of the
injured but we don't know anything
because there's no official list from
the authorities only lista has been
leaked but we don't know anything
nothing is known what the prisoners are
saying from inside is that no police or
military are controlling it that they
are letting them kill each other in cold
blood
police are blaming rival gangs for the
violence
these events are due to a territory
dispute by criminal gangs inside the
prison at the moment there are certain
pavilions that are without leaders
because this may be surprising to all
citizens but the leaders were released
after having served 60 of their sentence
at the same prison earlier this year
more than 100 inmates were killed in the
worst incident of prison violence in
recent years
ecuador's prison system has come under
the spotlight recently for overcrowding
and poor sanitation and living
conditions
officials say they are accommodating
about 9 000 more inmates than the
prisons were designed for
the literal penitentiary was built for 5
300 inmates but it holds
500.
in september president guillermo lasso
declared a two-month state of emergency
in the prison system
he's also called on the highest court to
allow the military to enter prisons to
stop any violence
the court responded in a statement
ecuador's prison crisis will require
more than temporary solutions
dorsa japari al jazeera